this just breaking right now breaking  news from foxnews.com  and brooke singman she is now reporting  that the laptop believed to be hunter  biden's  is in fact linked to an fbi money  laundering pro  pay attention the fbi allegedly  subpoenaed the laptop  and the hard drive in 2019. they've  known about this since 2019 which raises  a whole series of questions according to  this foxnews.com report quote  it is unclear at this point whether the  investigation is ongoing or  if it was directly related to hunter  biden is his laptop  multiple federal law enforcement  officials as well as two separate  government officials  have now confirmed the authenticity of  these documents  which was signed by fbi uh special agent  joshua wilson wilson did not immediately  respond  to fox news for a comment we will stay  on this story we're going to get  reaction in just a minute from senator  ron johnson but it is now breaking as we  speak